[Music]
Oh professor in comparative Media
Studies and I would like to introduce
our speaker tonight Emily rube who is a
reporter for the New York Times
she's also where she writes and produces
New York 101 a multimedia series that
really is about infrastructure in New
York and I'm intrigued by it because
it's about system and I'm intrigued by
her use of media as a system to get her
story telling apart
emily is currently a Nieman Fellow she's
a recipient of the Emmy as well as the
night baton award for innovation in
journalism and tonight we're here to
talk about innovation in story form we
know that newspaper readership in
general are declining a bit especially
take-up among young people is not what
it could be perhaps ought to be and we
know on the other hand that the media
forms that young folks are using tend to
be highly interactive and there are a
few pioneers out there pushing forward
with in legacy organizations and the
Times The Guardian des cités
digital would be examples of newspapers
that are kind of trying to find
experiment explore new ways of doing it
and emily is one of those pioneers one
of those explorers so we're here to hear
about her work tonight canary and a
couple of things to say one you might
know the hawk cam and behind me is the
person that brought that to life back in
2011 but it's in kind of precarious
shape now because of the state of flash
so the preservation of these innovations
is a real issue we've been looking at it
in the open doc lab a lot it's a problem
and I hope we hear a little bit about
that what do we do with print has the
great fortune of being stable what do we
do with some of these interactive
environments where stability is not
cannot be taken for granted we're also
looking at a moment of a medium in
transition I'm fairly convinced and so
we're watching that process play out I
want to also point out that the QA will
be off the record tonight so your
question
can be particularly sharp if you like so
great welcome great thank you for having
me so I am a reporter at The New York
Times I've been at the company for 11
years I started right after high school
that's a joke
let's joke joke joke joke so but in that
time I've just seen a tremendous amount
of change in the way that we tell
stories in the way that we reach our
readers so you know in the olden days
this this was our product and we knew
how to do it The Times knew how to do it
we you know fired up the presses we
gassed up the trucks sent them off flung
it at people's doorsteps and and once it
got there and once it got some
newsstands that we had done our job
1996 website appeared and and that
created a lot of tension in in the
newsroom which I'll talk about in a
little bit and then we have in the 2000s
does anybody know does anyone know what
this device is things got a little bit
more complicated in the 2000s and now
today we are swimming in media channels
whatsapp and text and you know phones
and alexa and and so you know all of
these ways that we you know we used to
be able to just tell one story and then
write it in the page and print it up and
now all of that has has that model has
kind of exploded so to speak so just a
little bit about me I got my start in
journalism in Paris and I worked for
publications like Time Out in Paris but
I also dabbled in radio and television I
lived in Scotland for a while I worked
at the BBC
and then also had more experience at the
Financial Times in London where I really
you know felt like I committed to
newspapers and magazines and so I felt
like you know print was sort of my my
medium but I also you know wasn't wedded
to it and felt like you know there were
there were other avenues to explore
which I will talk about in a minute
but I was hired in 2006 and back then
you know the building was it's now the
Yahoo building but it was 229 West 43rd
Street was you know this big hulking
building there were beautiful brass
doors and you know I was ready to go to
work there but actually this is where I
showed up to work this is 500 7th Avenue
which is where the website was so the
website we were an electronic media
company we had a separate work contract
we had a separate newsroom we had a
separate org chart we worked in separate
systems and we were down the street so I
you know you we would walk back and
forth between in Times Square Times
Square is named Times Square because of
the New York Times but you know we would
sort of see other web people sort of
walking back and forth in the rain to
like go to meetings at the paper so we
were you know kind of treated like these
we were on the JV team okay but that
also meant a lot of opportunities
because Oh print people were not really
paying attention to what we were doing
and so you know there were days I mean
it things had gotten better by the time
I arrived but there were there were even
editors that didn't want web people at
their meetings because they didn't want
to be scooped by the website so that's
the you know this is this is just a part
of the history of the times obviously
things are changing but I started and
travel and I was doing a lot of
multimedia
you know again as William pointed out
like uh most of my audio slideshows does
any does anyone know in an audio
slideshow is that was like the coin of
the realm back then and like you know
before Mark Bittman was like a thing I
would lock him in a closet and like get
good tape and do audio slideshows with
him and Frank Bruni and you know
experimented with you know sort of new
forms of storytelling trying to trying
to liven things up a little bit so it
was up to us really to think about you
know when the print you know editors had
like a big package it was up to us to
kind of figure out how to translate that
like the fifty three places to go but we
also made up stuff and I you know
started experimenting with audience
engagement so this was the frugal
traveler you know we sent him off with a
GPS device this is I know it sounds
totally ridiculous what yours this mm
like eight or nine and then you know
every night we would like upload his
like data for the day we hacked together
like this google map and we would you
know he would alter his route depending
on where readers wanted him to go and so
this is you know this is this new form
of this two-way interaction we were
actually you know listening to our
readers and trying to you know
incorporate you know what they had to
say and and and you know let them into
our reporting so we also redesigned the
this is all dead now by the way this
totally doesn't exist anywhere but we
redesigned the travel website and this
was also another instance where we you
know we you know there's a separation
between church and state editorial and
business do not mix at the times but
this was an instance where we were
really trying to build out these
destination pages and we partnered you
know with Expedia to put on a you know
like a booking module and we were also
building out these pages to engage
readers and ask for their insights about
where to go where to you know stay what
to eat so but that was a that caused
a tremendous amount of tension in the
newsroom because it was one of the first
projects of its kind where we were
actually really trying to monetize our
content so 2008 I joined the Metro desk
that does anyone know what City room is
so this is the heyday of blogs
okay the blogs at one point like The
Times had about 80 of them and City room
was one of the I would say one of the
highest it had one of the highest
metabolisms we were like producing 20
items a day and we you know had a small
team I was the I was the producer we had
you know a few reporters and editors and
you know we were really experimenting
our you know our mission really was to
promote civic engagement and to you know
really try to so there there was a
mission statement statement that said to
enhance and supplement Metro articles
from The Times offer non news features
about the history and civic culture of
the city and encourage reader comments
and discussion so that was our mission
statement and we went to town and the
great thing about our little world was
that
I kind of like when I was on travel you
know people were paying attention to
what we were doing but there wasn't a
lot of bureaucracy around you know we
didn't we didn't have to go very far to
just get permission to do things so we
we had a lot of latitude which was
incredible because we were able to you
know do things that were not very time
Xion right because The Times has a very
you know we have a reputation and to you
know to uphold certain standards and we
do want to do that but I think that what
City room did was in you know offer a
little bit more fun you know so and we
did a lot of series my job was to really
create series and
and regular features that would draw
readers back to the site and to
encourage their participation and create
that habit like every week I would you
know ask somebody like a window washer
or a you know a train operator or a
politician to come in and and ask
questions and another part of my job was
to you know really help print editors
rethink what a traditional story was
right because we editors pretty editors
know how to write that 800 word story
right you know it's like and and does
anyone know what a voices piece is so in
like you know newspaper parlance you
know the shorthand is like yeah we need
a voice this piece on that which is
literally a reporter going out and and
you know taking the temperature of
people about you know opinions about a
you know a new legislation or you know a
politician or an ER event and so this
was actually a real voices piece and
these were you know we were able to sort
of create this tableau voices literally
but you could actually connect with the
emotion in people's voices and also sort
of spatially you know see where people
are and you know it it it just you know
it was it was offering a new way to
present stories to to our readers now
here is one of my favorite projects so I
have been spending a lot of time or I've
always spent a lot of time thinking
about you know what I could do to engage
readers right what and and how do I
reach audiences now I am NOT a bird
watcher but my mom is in my I would go
on long walks with my brother and I
realized that bird watchers are very
smart they love data they're very
competitive
they love to share and there are a lot
of them like there you know I think you
know if bird-watching might have even
surpassed gardening as like you know
America's like most you know number one
pastime in America or a hobby so you
know and and also if you look at the
Venn diagram of The Times reader and the
bird watcher there was a lot of overlap
so I started going around the building
saying hey everybody I'm doing this
thing called bird week like Shark Week
but for birds and I you know I wasn't
really getting the reaction that I was
hoping for I had a lot of editors who
said to in particular who said you
really should not be wasting your time
on bird week and I said thanks okay
great so I went ahead and I I called up
the Cornell Lab of Ornithology I called
up New York City Audubon I found you
know people within the building who were
excited about birds
my friend David Dunlap well I'll tell
you about in a minute and I went ahead
and just started calling meetings
putting meetings on people's calendars
bad bird week I commissioned Mike Tyson
to defeat a defense of the pigeon he
said make a pigeon your friend and you
will never be lonely it was beautiful it
is a beautiful essay you know when on
WNYC and we you know started we
partnered with this company called
mobile Commons and we started you know
asking people where they want go
bird-watching and then my friend David
Dunlap tipped me off so this is David
Dunlap is you know horn-rimmed glasses
he wears a bowtie every day to work i
sat next to him you know you know he's
probably in his 60s very seasoned
reporter and I said David I said nobody
is interested in bird week and he said
said to me he you know over his
horn-rimmed glasses said fuck'em and
then he told me about this pair of
red-tailed hawks that were nesting
outside of NYU's president's office in
Washington Square Park that's I think
that's Bobby on the left and violet on
the right so there had been NYU
professors were already named the hawk
so I ran down to the office of course I
called them first and I think they rude
the day that they let me in their office
but I went down there and this is
actually the second iteration of the
hawk ham because the first one was
really I knew he had a livestream
account that nobody was really using and
I rummaged around in the supply closet
for a like a logitech you know one of
those like crappy little webcams and I
taped it to the curtains and then just
plugged it into the live streaming Canon
to started broadcasting and you know I
was like I said a message to Andy Newman
who was the bureau chief I was like is
this even cool like you know doesn't you
know like and he was like oh my god like
yeah we have to let go we have to go
live so as soon as you know I started
you know broadcasting this thing I
realized I had created a lot of problems
for myself because this was a 24 hour a
day 7 day a week stream okay and you
know I we couldn't interview our
subjects you know like but but the
bigger problem was
thing was happening so there was this
bird you know this Hawk sitting on the
nest every once in a while she would get
up and you know turn the eggs around and
I was starting to take a lot of heat you
know for my editors like okay but like
what's what's the point of this whole
thing Bill Keller who was former
executive editor of the New York Times
who was an opinion writer mentioned it
in reference to a Yule Log and so you
know so I was like all right we got a we
got it we got to do something about this
so you know you know we hosted the QAS
you know with ornithologist and and this
woman you know Maria Wynne who had
chronicled this other famous red tail
hawk we did you know shoe-leather
reporting but here was the cool part was
so this is the old live stream this is
there's nobody in the nest right there
but there was a chat room that was
bananas
there were people named like hip chick
pond of and these became our sources
because we started you know they were
the ones who started tipping us off you
know to events that were happening in
the nest then there was a a raptor
expert from Ohio John Blakeman who
started you know responding to some of
these questions because people were like
why you know why you know is the you
know why doesn't you know the father
hawk ever sleep on the nest you know
like and so you know people were
starting to criticize you know sort of
like they're you know bedroom habits and
so we had these you know another urban
hawk expert chimed in and you know
reassure people that's like normal
behavior so it was really you know these
people who were making this this story
they started and they started making it
their own so they sent us photos
they're animals and of course because
you know the key to reader engagement is
to rewarding it is to reward your
readers right you can't if you ask them
to submit something you want to
acknowledge you know their contribution
so we made a whole slideshow of pets
watching the hawk cam and then and then
things just you know blossomed off of
the site you know there this was
something I just couldn't control they
were making Twitter accounts there was
this woman who was house found in North
Carolina who you know was so inspired by
this and was connecting with these other
you know readers you know this it you
know she wrote all these letters and and
wrote and made these beautiful
illustrations this was you know helping
people transcend their everyday lives
and and and and also but they were
making it their own I mean this is like
the definition of viral content right
it's like you like these are memes you
know this is like this is people are
connecting with the content they're
putting their own little spin on it and
then they're sending it back out into
the internet so of course there was sort
of the happy ending and this is like a
tiny little baby hawk and baby Hawks are
very cute you know and but it was you
know it ended up being this phenomenon
in the first season it ran for four
seasons the first season I think people
spent a hundred and fifty million
minutes watching this an average of 16
minutes a person so you know some might
say that that the you know that was
those were hours of lost productivity
but I prefer to call that engagement you
know it was there were teachers who were
watching with their students there were
ornithologists who were you know
observing these birds up close in this
urban environment you know that they
wouldn't normally get to see because
normally you know usually when they
encounter them there under duress or
they're hurt or something and so this
was a chance for them to study these
birds you know while they were going
about their daily business and it also
just you know inspired people to be in
awe of their environment and then they
started to connect with each other in
real life so so if you can see they've
got their nametags on so these are their
chat room handles so you know so it was
you know just the you know there's so
many lessons of the hawk cam you know
about believing in your own ideas and
and just going with with you know your
gut instinct and and not listening to
naysayers but also that this was the low
the the technology was was so simple
that it really you know when you're
thinking about you know creative and
immersive storytelling you know you
don't have to have expensive gear and
you know it's really about creating
content that is that readers connect to
emotionally so you know so we created
this you know sort of teed up this story
and then readers sort of made it their
own experience so there are pitfalls
however of reader generated content so
readers are terrific resource however
there are they're they're not always
perfect so this is in 2013 it we were
covering the mayor's race and you know I
always like I again you know instead of
covering you know the you know the panel
discussions or the debates I wanted to
create something that celebrated or
recognized that you know the people
every day who are you know little heroes
on their block and their community as a
way to to you know engage with New
Yorkers but also ask readers you know
who who is meaningful to you so we put
out this call
and you know we got 200 very thoughtful
responses and when we went through all
of them most of the responses however
were of people nominating their mom
which is nice but you know everyone's
not everyone's mom is you know a hero
this guy nominated himself 20 times and
so you know there while readers are a
really great resource you know it really
you know you still have to we still had
to do a lot of our own reporting to to
vet the entries but also to make this to
make this project a success so we did
you know the old oldie tiny print
presentation but then we also created
these little video vignettes and I
worked with two incredible photographers
to to really just capture the essence of
some of these characters and this is
this is Gena sakala she has been sitting
outside of her stoop on Spring Street
since John Gotti
you know wandered the neighborhood isn't
him do we know who John Gotti is my
mobster guy who would like you know you
know give the kids ice cream and stuff
like that so you know and she's she's a
relic of this of this
that's Edna the Comptroller so the point
the point of that is that they're you
know experimenting with the audio and
video and you can really you know you
can read about Gina and I can I can
quote what she says on the page but
she's someone you really want to hear
from so another project that we that I
worked on was every every couple of
years the times you know and in many
news organizations you know talked about
the noise in the city and how it is a
constant problem the challenge is making
something like this visual you know we
you know when we we tried several
tactics to try and sort of connect
readers to this invisible force right so
we we rented out dosimeter which
measures decibel levels and you know
created these little noise Diaries where
we follow it around you know a handful
of characters just to show the level of
noise exposure that they received every
day but and that was it was interesting
but it was not like a big success this
on the other hand was much more powerful
so in when I'm thinking about multimedia
we like to you I like to think about it
as like
zigging and zagging right you've got
your print piece that is like it's gonna
do the due diligence of like it's really
loud in New York City and here are the
experts who are gonna tell you that and
then have the multimedia do something
completely different so for this we just
turned the idea on its head and asked
people where do you find peace and
in New York City and work with a
developer to map a lot of these
submissions so we got about 800
submissions and then I went out with a
photographer and and an audio recorder
and we again rewarding readers we
decided to create these audio-visual
postcards like a little like a moment of
Zen
you know so trying to create sort of
this immersive experience where you know
if you're at your you know desk at lunch
you know sit back put on your on your
headphones and and you can't you can't
hear it but there's like birds chirping
beautiful garden queen or in yeah Dan
Island
we're on Staten Island Ferry and so
again we were trying to create this
immersive experience but working with
readers and also rewarding them again
for their contributions by adding you
know a pull quote and creating this you
know this display so it was it was also
a really fun project to report because
we I for like four days I just drove all
around Manhattan with an audio recorder
and just went into some of the most
incredible beautiful places so my latest
project New York 101 is as William said
it's about infrastructure but you know
as a you know as journalists you know I
feel a strong as a journalist I feel a
strong duty to educate and so a big part
of the series is is making people more
aware of their surroundings and and
but also creating ways into difficult
and complex systems that's the hardest
part about infrastructure is that it's
everywhere and it is really hard to find
a way in because it's just hard to know
where to start and so you know I worked
with a an editor Mike Luo who's now at
The New Yorker but you know he was it
was his idea to say you know to you know
to cover infrastructure but it's like
okay well but what does that mean
and so as you'll see I you know it kind
of went all over the place and how I was
trying to establish this beat you know
but my goal ultimately was like making
infrastructure talk so here was one of
the first I worked with Delta so
airports and Airlines are amazing
sources of data they because everything
is recorded and like you know so there's
a lot of if your data nerds group so
many cool data sets in there but I
worked with them to you know help break
down the process of like what happens
when a plane touches down at JFK one of
the busiest airports you know in North
America from the time it touches down to
the time it takes off because Delta
doesn't make any money when the planes
are on the ground so they know every
like down to the second where their
plane is and where their mechanics are
and so I you know worked with them to
you know detail the number of pounds of
jet fuel that were loaded into the plane
how many cans of tomato juice went into
it and so you know taking sort of this
behind-the-scenes look at at you know
what goes on in airports and I don't
have it here but and I used gifts
because who doesn't like a gift I also
you know you know wrote about people you
know a big part of the series is also
highlighting the people who were you
work behind the scenes this is Sal
Magaddino he's like a former major
crimes detective at the NYPD and he is
standing on this giant book sorter
okay so he runs this he runs this
department called book ops like book
operations book ops so he works with
like you know former military guys who
are like logistics experts from like you
know Iraq and like you know have like
deployed platoons and now they're like
they got this again they know like where
all their books are and they were like
if a patron has an urgent request we
could remove that truck so I you know
they took me behind the scenes to you
know their their headquarters and you
know showed me all of their the maps and
you know like their service
you know routes and everything and so I
worked with them again I knew that they
had this great data set I wrote a story
about the you know about Sal and this
book sorting competition that they have
every year with the Seattle Public
Library so there was like a news peg
there but but the more fun part was
actually tracking a book I checked out
Breakfast at Tiffany's
and like send it to Staten Island and we
were they were able so so they knew that
I was doing this and they were able to
give me the actual timestamps of like
when and where it like went through you
know the system and when it went on that
book sorter that that we just saw you
know as a way to actually you know show
people like when you check out your book
that book and there have been a lot of
people who have like made that you know
made that happen I also wrote about an
archaeologist for hire and I but instead
of I wrote about her work but I also as
a sidebar I thought it would be cool
to do a deep dive of one building that
has sort of been at the crossroads of
cultural political change you know for
four centuries right beginning with like
the bull said tavern where George
Washington you know rallied his troops
and it was like this German beer hall is
a Yiddish vaudeville theatre - you know
tracing the evolution and working with
archivists at New York Times has an
amazing archivist Jeff Roth who is a an
archiving dad those are not my words
somebody else called him and archiving
God and track down you know old building
records I worked with him you know you
mean Municipal Archives to to really you
know sort of take readers through the
history of New York City through this
one building this was the breakthrough
for the series and it was you know it
was timely because Flint there were
issues you know people in Flint Michigan
were you know drinking out of bottle of
water they were you know bathing in
bottled water and because the city had
switched the source of their water and
they were they hadn't adequately tested
it so I wanted to write something that
wasn't alarmist and I also wanted to
write something that was going to last
beyond the headlines and have some
staying power because you know there's a
that's something that you know our news
organization is is getting better at but
you know the there is like an impulse to
like write that day story and just to
get it in the paper right
whereas this you know I wanted it to be
you know like an investigation but a
contextual invest investigation that
would help people sort of think and and
perhaps even appreciate the work that
goes into delivering their water every
day so you know it you know I went
through a lot of boring reports
also did a snapchat story does anyone
use snapchat here yeah so I use snapchat
you know and I went you know to the
Catskills and traced you know the waters
journey you know all the way to a tap in
you know where I literally you know turn
on a tap in in Manhattan and it was you
know it was a way to reach another
audience but it was also it informed my
reporting and so I you know had at that
point was able to sort of break down
sort of this is my own little drawings I
was able to sort of create sort of a not
a mock-up but just some kind of proof of
concept that I brought to a designer and
you know it turns out it's very very
talented designer Matt Ruby and it turns
out that he had this idea or had had
this idea of creating a new story format
that wasn't a vertical scroll that was
horizontal and that readers could flip
through and so you know we work together
in a Google Doc you know which is for
the sake of transparency I mean a lot of
reporters are resistant to that idea
because you know you're showing somebody
your raw copy and so there's you know
people get kind of nervous about that
but I just sort of threw it all in there
and my first draft was about 4,000 words
and then he told me if we do it this way
I each panel would have to be about 200
to 400 words so I that was the real work
was really narrowing it down and really
refining it and me and you know
simplifying it but without losing
accuracy and I think that in the end it
was it was really powerful because it
had fewer words
and so you know that story just gained a
lot of attention because it really made
people think differently or it presented
a new option for even for editors right
who are who are sort of storyboarding
some of their some of their you know
ideas I investigated the roads and you
know again went through a similar
process thinking maybe I'll just you
know answer a bunch bunch of questions
but I ended up just answering one simple
questions and as you'll see you know I'd
to you know I worked with Grant oops
grant Gould who was like a really
talented designer and we worked or we
used we tried to break up the text with
with headlines with with illustrations
that were that are not quite graphics
but that are you know that are doing
some of the work that are telegraphing
information but that are also pleasing
and so you know we've played with you
know using sort of these pull quotes
just to help people find sort of ways in
and and you know so even if you just
wanted to sort of scan it you could just
you know there were lots of chunky
blocks of text that would offer you know
a little bit of variety because it's you
know it's road construction
I mean how interesting is that turns out
very interesting so but you can read all
about it so then you know I one of the
hardest pieces was the power grid how
often do you think about your
electricity bill your you what do you
have Con Ed here know National Grid and
eversource how often do you think about
your elect your source of electricity
Oh a lot o clothes a lot
alright well case in point you really if
infrastructure is a bit like love you
just don't know what you've got until
it's gone so so this we work really hard
to really just pare this down again I
got to work with Matt Ruby and you know
the the goal was really just making
something you know using very short
simple sentences of this these drawings
are not very clear but just trying to
really break down the process in a way
that didn't use flowery language that
unspooled the concepts very very simply
and I worked with many experts who read
behind me including my dad who worked
for the Department of Energy for a while
and has worked in engineering just to
make sure that this was accessible and
we got a great reader response that you
know of people one guy said you know you
know he's never gonna think about you
know flipping on the light switch in the
morning the same way again and that to
me is a win um but also you know
professors or he said they were using it
in their curriculum but it was it was a
it was an exercise in restraint and this
this package really was about
simplifying and and a lot of these
stories are really about simplifying so
what's next I'm just going to show you a
few more examples and then open up for
questions this is has anyone seen the
360 videos this was cool because I got
to go escort the Queen Mary out of New
York Harbor with the Harbor pilots so
you know the times I guess is one of the
only or one of the first to you know
really dive into 360 video and it's
really cool because it it Springs
readers to a place as they wouldn't
otherwise have access to like you know
the cockpit of this you know of the
Queen Mary and then also climbing down
the ladder you know like wow another you
know ship is sort of running alongside
of it
so taking readers and giving them the
sort of incredible experience but also
giving them control of their frame
because you can drag the cursor and you
can actually choose your own so this is
participatory you are letting reader
sort of you know navigate their way in
the story now you know the times
partnered with Samsung and you know
we've had one of these a day and so you
know which we can talk about it has it
has pluses and minuses of you know
introducing a new technology into the
newsroom which really dictates you know
a demand for the story so you know I
have mixed feelings about that happy to
talk about that has anyone seen the AR
stuff it's really cool you know that the
mobile phone is like the platform du
jour
so this is the times is augmented
reality one of their first which
essentially brought these Olympians into
your living room
so whereas 360 video takes you somewhere
that you wouldn't normally go AR
actually meets you where you are and
brings this experience to you so you
know this is if you have a you know even
a semi recent iPhone you can actually
get this experience on your phone you
can just hold it up and you know this
ice skater forgetting his name Chen will
appear in your living room
and then or David Bowie this was the
second one and they're really working I
talked to Graham Roberts who's like
running this new department and he said
something I liked about thinking about
the phone right it's like we used to
think about it as like this
like a surface right and now they're
thinking about it like a window which
actually I just really liked because so
when you so they they used
photogrammetry to take these very
detailed pictures of the costumes that
were going to be on display at the
Brooklyn Museum and interspersed it with
with text so they're really trying to
you know create this augmented reality
experience in the context of the story
so you don't have to like click away and
you know you your experience of reading
the story is interrupted and this is the
last example does anyone read the
Metropolitan diary
yeah metropolitan area so this is the
Times's longest-running user generated
column it started in 1976 as a mail bag
and in 2011 I there were editors who
were again not that enthusiastic about
it because it was its time intensive you
know people write in these stories is a
reader stories about moments that they
have you know over that they overheard
or like an interaction with the cab
driver or like you know or like a missed
connection you know or just like a these
are heartwarming stories there's poetry
a lot of bad poetry and so you know in
2011 or 2012 I can't remember you know I
just realized that there was a huge
opportunity here and so I dragged it out
and started producing it in another way
so that each each diary entries stood
alone we started at a metadata to it and
then you know giving readers an actual
byline which is a big deal in the olden
days when that when the column started
people if your submission was accepted
the times I'd send you a bottle of
champagne where we don't do that anymore
um but so now you get you know you get
the byline and and in sort of an entree
into this sort of prestigious you know
this cannon of you know New York history
and then allowed people to comment on it
so so then I took decided to take it one
step further which was like AR 1.0 and I
a friend of mine at work Chris Wiggins
is the chief data scientist connected me
with Matt Condon who is a super talented
developer who helped who created an app
because I thought well wouldn't it be
kind of cool if you know we were to
create an app you know that surfaced you
know or allowed people to search for all
of these different diary entries and you
know to have them all in one place and
you could search for you know stories
that are like related to dogs or you
know or that we're just poems well or
what if you were to you know have on
your phone this app and it would know
where you are now again there's some
privacy issues here of course but it was
location aware and it surfaced a diary
entry that was near to you and so so
this is yeah I'll just turn off the
sound but this is this was essentially
the way it worked now this is not ever
going to be a product this is not like
you know it's too it's too niche but you
know it does sort of I mean really
interests me and because you know I'm
I'm very curious about what's next about
you know location aware storytelling you
know it there's a there there's a
incredible opportunity here to you know
interact and and also present
information and that's what mostly
excites me about AR is is you know this
idea of like layering information and
you know the time says it's like
incredible archive you know photos of
articles and I'm just imagining you know
holding your phone up you know and if I
could do that 50 Bowery story about
one building in New York City you know
you could hold up your phone and you can
you know sort of see the history you
know right then and there you know it's
you know there's there's there's
there're a lot of opportunities to to be
you know to discuss you know that time
says this incredible body of knowledge
you know in terms of restaurant reviews
and in terms of its you know expertise
in climate science and so it's really
exciting to think about you know what
the times we'll be doing next and you
know there's a lot of thoughtful
discussion about how technology can be
used to you know enrich people's lives
with information and that is like that's
where I see sort of AR and like my job
or whatever I do next is is to you know
and also to create this collaborative
and this iterative process to to make
the news
you